for today's classic interview we're
going back to an industry that I've
learned a lot more about since the
original interview with tansy Hoskins
aired in October 2014 the fashion
industry as any number of horrors that
many of us may not know about unless
we've learned more about the
manufacturing of clothing fast fashion
and everything that is implied by that
growing industry I don't think I need
more of an introduction this is a very
interesting interview with someone who
knows a lot about this industry
tancy Hoskins we'll go back to October
29th of 2014
take a look I'm joined today by tansy
Hoskins who's an activist and author of
stitched up the anti-capitalist book of
fashion which is a critical look at the
practices of the modern fashion industry
I want to start first with globalization
and exploitation which are two things
you talk about in the book people
probably in the US and the UK have a
general understanding when they hear
those terms that oh sweatshop labor
child labor but that may be as far as
their understanding of exploitation and
globalization go there's much more to it
than that isn't there yes there
certainly is I mean if you take a
country like Bangladesh globalization
has meant the destruction of local local
traditional industries like fishing and
farming which is driven huge migration
into the capital city data and into
other sort of industrial hubs so it is
an entire process and I guess you know
it's not just sort of the goods that we
see travelling around the world you also
get migration of people going all around
the world yes so this is a great deal
with with globalization you know you get
the you get enormous globalized
corporations which are acting globally
you know so borders don't play the role
that they used to play so capital is you
know you can have a country based in
London it can
Manufacturing in Bangladesh and then it
could be selling in in a business in the
United States but what we don't have at
the moment and was the big problem in
the fashion industry is a lack of and no
global legislation to go to go with that
to protect people and we're only just
seeing the rise of global trade unions
to try and ameliorate the rate some of
these processes it's similar to what's
happening happening in fact with
internet law in many cases where because
you have things taking place on the
Internet in kind of the abstract sense
that cross country lines it can be hard
to legislate in a way that both make
sense based on how the internet is
actually used but also takes into
consideration the kind of multinational
impacts of what is happening on the
Internet and similarly when we have a
situation where an American company
presumably American company is sourcing
their clothes from other countries where
the labor practices may well be legal in
that country al biet unethical how do
you create a system of law that takes
that into consideration given that the
eventual vendor of the cup clothing is
in the United States where those
practices would be illegal
yeah I think that companies are
responsible and legally responsible for
their supply chain because they are they
are the ultimate factor in that supply
chain they have the ultimate control
over things like wages and Environmental
Protection and all the standards and so
you have to you know I'd like to see
there being legislation about goods that
come into the UK you know that clothes
that come into the into the UK and a
much more transparent set of supply
chains as well there's a movement here
in the US and I don't know if it also
exists in the UK which is that of
produced locally right and sometimes the
defenders of the globalized apparel
status quo so to speak will say well if
you think that that American Apparel
white t-shirt is expensive now just wait
until it's produced here in the United
States paying us minimum wages how would
you respond to someone who
then the status quo with that type of
argument mm well I mean I'm certainly
not in favor of pitting you know workers
in Bangladesh against workers in you
know in Britain or America I mean we've
seen in Britain and indeed in America
the gradual running down of
manufacturing you know Britain used to
be a huge manufacturing hub as did
America and you know successive
governments have had a deliberate policy
of running that down and that's
certainly true for the for the garment
industry and the key reason you know why
companies don't manufacture in Britain
and in America is is because of wages so
when I would like to see wages rise in
you know across Asia I'm in favor of the
beige you know living wage campaigns and
the Asian the Asia floor wage that try
and create a standard and minimum
standard for the production of all of
our grid there's another kind of layer
to this that for me only exacerbates the
problems with the wages that are being
paid to the workers in many of these
countries and maybe people don't know
this the margins on individual clothing
items are just huge I mean people may
not know that a luxury handbag sells for
10 to 12 times what it costs to produce
we're talking about a thousand or twelve
hundred percent markup I mean many
dresses and shirts are selling for
exponentially more than what the cost is
to produce and this to me only further
infuriates me in terms of not only are
the workers being swindled and maybe
that it's actually worse than being
swindled but the buyers are also paying
a price that makes no sense whatsoever
and somehow the market is bearing that
price hmm yes certainly I mean it's like
you're getting exploitation both at the
point of production and at the point of
consumption and we know with with prices
being quite so high but only on a sort
of positive side as it were
they've been various studies that are
showing that in order to double why
for garment workers all you have to do
is increase the price of sale address by
between 1 and 3% and then amazing
because you would only have to increase
absurdly inflated prices by 1 to 3% to
double the wages that are being paid
it's incredible isn't it it is
incredible and it you know it just shows
just how greedy these corporations are
you know companies like Burberry who
which are billion-dollar billion-dollar
companies or Marks and Spencers that
makes you know over 600 million pounds
in profit every single year and yet they
won't pay a living wage either in
Bangladesh or in you know in the shops
as well in in places like in London here
I would actually be much less offended
by the prices that are charged by the
companies if I knew that they valued the
employees in a way that they really
redistributed the profits to those
employees in a significant way in other
words I just don't want both being
absurdly embarrassingly overcharged for
items I know cost a couple of dollars to
produce and knowing that that the
majority of that money is not going to
the workers yeah no I mean yes I mean I
completely agree it just shows you know
where the priorities of these come of
these companies are which is you know is
not with the people that are on making
them these gigantic profits what
clothing buying practices can the
average person learn that can at least
mitigate how much they're exacerbating
this problem and I word it that way
because if you're buying clothing it's
difficult to not be a part of the
problem at all to completely remove
yourself but what advice can you give to
people mmm
well I mean I like like personally in
the in the work that I do I I encourage
people not just to think of themselves
as consumers and I encourage people to
think of the the action that they do and
the help you know in the sort of
solidarity they show with garment
workers not to be you know when
they're in the shops I don't think you
can change the system we live in by
shopping differently and I don't think
we can buy the kind of justice that we
that we all want to see so I'm much more
concerned with getting people involved
in you know like trade union solidarity
campaigns and in like you know picketing
and pressurizing a big corporations like
like Walmart Walmart and Gap who have
refused to even sign the Bangladesh
Accord on building and fire safety I'm
asking if you've got you know if you've
got a choice between two different
garments and you could afford to make
that choice then of course make the
choice that's least harmful to people
and planet but for many people there you
know there's not a great deal of choice
involved in what they buy and I think
those people have the right to be
involved in in changing the world as
well I'll remind our audience the book
is stitched up the anti-capitalist book
of fashion we've been speaking with the
book's author tansy Hoskins great to
have you on really a great topic and
something I think it's important for
people to know about thank you thank you
thank David